she's selling it's spicy I'm gonna watch
it let's watch it
hi guys it's Adam Greg album and this is
Xenia
Ksenia almost one more time what a lot
right Sicily sin yeah but you're close
ii was you know i had a nail before I
learned what your name man and I'm gonna
be murdered we have Kelly Russo here so
these two lovely ladies we're willing to
come on the channel today also they
wanted to promote something here they
are starring in a short film an action
short film called man ears why don't you
guys give a quick little backless you
said it just won some award that I
forgot everybody's you're trying to get
into other spots we just won the my road
real for the best action film and we got
nominated for the best comedy and we've
won and give a shout-out to our director
Nick Acosta who directed it and did all
the amazing special effects and
everything garnished and yeah we just
entered another competition which is the
film convert pro film convert I think
there's no pro in there I don't know why
I put it Pro yeah so check it out please
and vote because we need votes and we
just submitted to Sundance and slam
dance you're trying to get in there Wow
so we can go to Utah have some fun but
more importantly you guys assuming you
guys have seen the trailer I'm gonna
check out the trailer right now yeah
yeah I'm gonna watch this trailer let's
watch along with you guys only 40
seconds long because it's a short film
that is half of the length of the actual
film true you guys don't talk I'm gonna
watch
everyone be quiet
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
do you like guys that looks really
professional looks really good honestly
we live in LA and a lot of people show
me a lot of the [ __ ] that are working on
and a lot of times I'm like yeah but
that looked like really pro mean like if
you take this like frame by frame these
I'm talking right into the microphone
for you guys as if we're doing a radio
talk show now like these shots of like
is that you getting punched in the face
of the camera right there wow this looks
like a lot right now yeah they put a lot
of work there's a lot of CGI and like
really cool stuff I did and she went on
a plane and then we just push her out
this short film costs $100,000 but it
was worth it and I know sky dived and
actually like I actually like the
premise a lot too of like it seems like
you were just two regular girls on a bar
who want to hit on a guy but you girls
are gonna kill him
which is Ryan I've been in that
situation we got and the double entendre
talked about well I had to bury their
bodies cuz no one could defeat me good
point
please don't hurt me when we're done
but no that actually looks really
perfect way I mean can't when can people
see this can people watch our record
yeah it's on the my road real official
website under the winners section oh and
yeah and please please check it out on
film phone convert bro I can't there's
no pro there's no you know those I'm
watching her crack up at herself I'm
hearing you say the word yes you're in
chaos right now Three's Company yes make
a sitcom but yeah I mean how long is the
actual work three minutes actually okay
to fit everything into three-minute yeah
I like the title it looks like bad times
at the Ellroy yeah we came out before
that trailer did yeah so screw you guys
you totally copy this but Nick Acosta
we've worked with them a lot and yeah
it's just fun we make a creative useful
thing well actually represents the two
colors represent our characters here wow
you can really amplify that I didn't
even notice your accent till like way
way later kind of world where Russians
don't put it out there for people to say
no it is pretty intimidating that's my
American mind
Wow yeah I mean from knowing you for an
hour-and-a-half and knowing you for
about six hours in total if you combine
the amount of time you spend together I
calculate every time I hang out with
someone you you both seem like you'd be
perfect for this role these both these
roles because you both are strong women
who are tough but have this like
sensitive quality to you first time I
saw you you did get tough I mean I hope
we could talk about if it was an
interview where I was watching an edit
go down where you were standing up to
someone some dude about that's a messed
up stuff the son of a very famous
director yeah oh really yeah and it's I
saw her going out like that was my first
impression of Kelly it was do not mess
with his girl right there that's why
when I think that's why we have like
mutual respect for each other before we
even met because she has this energy
yeah but then you talk to me like you
know and you're solo no I mean no I it
takes a lot to get me mad but I'm
Italian so me too it's placing you know
I got the sensitive side I'm sensitive
Italian I do not fit in well in Italy or
New York
strange why not Italy they love
sensitive guys there yay
it's alright my girlfriend's a tough
when she counterbalances musi we get
along with her really well okay you like
alpha alpha ladies yeah that's great
yeah she's on top all right good to know
yeah I think being a tough woman
nowadays it's different it you know and
you were talking earlier like
vulnerability is part of being tough and
you know you can't just bulldoze people
and tell them what is hair day you know
just yeah stand up for mine my days of
bulldozing people are over
[Music]
why yeah because it's wrong what Kelly
said yeah it's wrong a conversation I
felt bad yeah but that's how you promote
your these kind of things well yeah I
don't want to see this actually looks
really wonderful the action looks
impressive you two look like you're
giving pretty awesome performances and
yeah and Nicolas is his name yeah
Nicolas Acosta hey um you do you want my
profile shot for a future audition right
just now is your audition laid sleep my
name is Greg Alba I'm from North
Hollywood California and I love hiking
what's your deepest fear vulnerability
even vegan on camera
[Laughter]
guys go vote to where you said to vote
you better text me some links and yeah
it's election time and check out the
short film in the link I'm gonna go
watch it right away
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell and follow these two
on Instagram but especially Twitter see
you guys